as promised I played some smite with you
bros and here are some highlights from
our gameplay if you guys are gonna I'm
gonna swap you out there attacking our
tactic is just to protect me that's yes
okay what should I pick as a new some
range guy right yeah I'll pick a range I
picked the one with the biggest tip yeah
now I'm going I'm going with the girls
for the tits wait they all have tits to
lose right away how about that let's do
it alright good good good good luck team
nice I'm sliding awesomeness of course
okay okay I got it I got it no problem
no problem
yeah easy should I buy [ __ ] you know why
buy all the [ __ ] you can my favorite
type of [ __ ] that's it
I don't know why my walking animation is
about you ever again okay are there lane
serves in one lane there's three three
why aren't we divided yep I don't see
any lane I'm not express this but I mean
II expecting much more like first aren't
anyway I don't expect much for me for
like any round yeah well I guess same
goes for me honestly I stop you okay
it's done I mean no my son I mean of
course of course obviously no shed he's
doing something help help
jumping test some help oh oh oh that guy
that guy looks mighty thirsty for pids
help he has a horse it's not fair will
hacks on an open arena yet make so much
sense I've got all my [ __ ] oh my god I
killed so on I mean of course of course
first ever kill its might I've gotten to
a chat with seananners and I'm chatting
with pewds I'm a lucky guy
it's good stuff advice man do some sexy
moves yeah I'm doing so many sexy moves
if only you could see me who's saying I
can't queued outside with binoculars
outside my room yes
at the same time links my oh [ __ ] I'm
dead no you're not you're fine you're
fine just hold your breath no not a bit
what are you talking about help help
help
no no how do I see this more one three
ouch oh no oh no did you guys lose no
yeah yeah what are you talking Lin wait
I want to see my dance better be a good
dance so you know nice dance alright
well that was fun well thanks guys
oh cool someone's mic is really bad but
that's okay sounds like you have a
vibrator next to your face or something
don't worry about it we have to win this
one no matter what no excuses all right
you guys ready for some morena let me
hear your battle cry
yeah let's do it
I can't think I can't believe this is
actually happening this is really bad
is that a baby or a man that's the
question I mean I think he's a very aged
[ __ ] with a lot of extra fat and those
small Lex can run oh hell yeah I don't
even have to run I just you know be
fabulous I guess I don't I don't I know
take it back what I said get that [ __ ]
I'm missing everything
Oh help horse help I can't go on
I am the best player in the world cute
is on a rampage
I had like 1% health guys supposed to go
in there I don't think so oh [ __ ] I
don't know take their portal I just want
to kill this one guy come on come on my
life is like we exist I know don't try
to take credit for my awesome tail I'm
sorry I seal all the kills oh come on
guys come on guys yeah did I win we did
Oh
have so much gold I didn't even buy
anything all right guys we got to swap
out but it was fun to play already
what's fun yes indeed that's pretty much
been the best day yeah you're just
saying that you were the best on the
team of course all right thanks guys
All Right see ya thank you thank you you
ready to kick some butt we lost two good
two matches so far so we have to win
hope this guy has to TRS I'll be that
guy big boss the guy is the tank okay
who's gonna tank on the horse guy that
guy kept killing me all the time every
other game the guy with a horse just
kept killing me first time I don't care
I don't care what happens just have to
kill people
oh nice oh [ __ ] run run run baby so
scary oh nice
Bieber get Bieber Bieber is going down
Oh kill steal hell yeah I met IIIi don't
know what happened I I sneezed and
there's no K essing in Korea arena yeah
we're a team
gosh arena's free life I'm sorry if what
happened again maybe Oh probably line
running [ __ ] that baby oh hey come here
come a cricket we're gonna have to
ignore him now we can get him
horse time [ __ ] yeah that's right
nice yeah the other baby stuff to be
able to go [ __ ] the baby so tired of his
[ __ ]
yeah nice now we get the baby coming a
little [ __ ] I'm gonna chase you you
[ __ ] baby
nevermind my horse will dump my horse
[ __ ] the baby Oh gang gang-bang the baby
don't want to go there
[Music]
mitch is so fast come back here yeah god
I love the horse the horse is like the
best thing ever made wait up god damn it
it may say defeat but that doesn't
really mean we lost it was finalizing
with you all right bye guys
thank you
[Music]
Aoyama we have 200 screaming people in
the other channel yeah I'll take so
she's really okay if that's okay
whatever let us win button mashing for
me this roll your face on the keyboard
you'll be fine yeah okay what who are
you here where I am here that do a
little dance otherwise that other oh
cool it's a teleport even necessary on
this map like don't laugh how dare you
you don't know my tactics I'm trapped
Oh No horsey time [ __ ] taste my horse
I don't know how it tastes like my
character isn't moving what the hell
okay Pichu go kill them I run away okay
sure
horsie horsie horsie horsie I'm trying
exert all the backflips no we are
waiting
I just dropped us here subconsciously
yeah this is the best game so far I like
I don't care if we win or lose it's
still fun I lied we have to win that was
a test that's what I do
oh [ __ ] I got helium I died because my
fault thanks it's okay it's okay
it's because of the crowd if the card
wasn't there we would have yeah you know
all right guys I gotta I gotta go but it
was fun playing with you oh that's fun
thank you yeah thanks for the
opportunity
hey yeah it's nothing how about you
anymore I want to say one thing
thanks for the videos that you are
uploading it's really fun too
I'm at 3 a.m. when I can sleep you know
get it that's good to show ya I'm right
they help though Thanks
daily doses before you go to bed when
it's out last is done you know hello I'm
sorry I couldn't play with all of you
alright guys it's my awesome
alright press we didn't win any games
but I still had a lot of fun playing
with you I'm definitely gonna play more
smite so you ever find me online
download link is in the description also
thanks to g2a for hooking me up with
free skins and stuff like that let me
know if there's any other free-to-play
games that you want to play with me I'll
gladly check it out I have so much fun
let's do more of these I really liked it
I hope you enjoyed watching leave a like
if you did
hits the sky come over today and I'll
see you in the next time we play
[Music]